tell someone i need help like i think it
is one of us it's one of these skills
that is becoming fast lost
especially amongst a younger generation
which is the skill to ask for help you
know we're all trying to act so tough
you know this this nation over indexed
on the whole rugged individualism thing
you know
where we defined success as individual
success
um and and most of our metrics most of
our incentives and almost every job are
individual incentives there you know
there's no team bonus there's an
individual bonus if you hit your numbers
you know
um and uh i think we've we've over did
it quite frankly
uh and i think it's the pendulum needs
to come back uh and and
and we have to remember that we're a
team we're members of teams we're
members of families remember communities
we're members of societies and this is
where maslov got it wrong you know
maslov's hierarchy of needs he says you
know fundamentally at the bottom of the
pyramid is food and shelter um and he
put you know third you know third up the
rung he put uh uh uh
relationships well i've never heard of
anyone dying by suicide
because they were hungry i've heard of
people dying by suicide because they
were lonely so in other words it can't
be right and at the top you have
self-actualization how or like i'm all
self-actualized looking down at the rest
of you who aren't at the top of the
pyramid what about shared actualization
you know and the mistake he made is that
there's a paradox which is every moment
of every day
we are both individuals and members of
groups and every day we have to
reconcile that do i put myself first at
the expense of someone else or do i
prioritize someone else at the expense
of myself
and the answer is you're right you're
wrong and there's a whole group of
people that says no no you always take
care of yourself first because if you're
not healthy you can't help others and
there's another group of people says no
you always help others first because
unless you help them they won't be there
for you it's a paradox it doesn't work
it's not so clean
um and this is what we have to reconcile
every day
and this is why finding balance and
managing it and the stresses and trains
but the the challenge of asking for help
and relying on our community really
really matters
my my definition of faith
is that knowing you're on a team even
when you don't know who all the players
are um
we are surrounded by people who love us
and will take care of us you just have
to ask sometimes because sometimes they
don't know that we need it